(light sniffles)
- [Mark] Okay, let's
start; what was your name?
- Hazel.
And you are?
- [Mark] Mark.
- Nice to meet you.
- [Mark] Nice to meet
you. All right, Hazel.
Hazel, what neighborhood
did you grow up in?
- [Hazel] I grew up in east L.A.
- [Mark] East L.A. so-
- [Hazel] I'm from Mecho Trece Gang
- [Mark] Which gang?
- [Hazel] Mecho Trece
(indistinct)
Everybody knows it.
- [Mark] I don't.
I'm new at the gang (indistinct)
- Some people know
- [Mark] What age were you
when you joined the gang?
- I was fourteen
- [Mark] Fourteen?
Tell me about your childhood a little bit.
You grow up with both parents?
- I grew up with-
at fourteen I was on my own.
- [Mark] Fourteen.
- I ended up being on my own because
(loud traffic bustle)
I had a
I guess you could say
I had a dysfunctional
family, that's for sure but
- [Mark] Tell me how you grew up.
Both parents? One parent?
- When I was younger, I grew
up with, I had both my parents
but my dad's, even to this
day, he's a alcoholic.
Growing up, he was a alcoholic.
My mom, she was into drugs, you know.
My dad too.
My parents used to be
swingers, apparently.
- [Mark] Oh really?
- That's kinda like a
no-no, like you don't just
You know?
I mean, not if you're
from the hood, though.
- [Mark] So alcohol and drugs were forever
in your parents' lives and then-
What were you on the street at? Fourteen?
- [Hazel] Fourteen. Trying
to, I guess look for
love and acceptance, you know? but
I found it in my hood, in my neighborhood,
and I met a few people and just
I was always the one to
say that I never wanted
to be from the hood
To have to show nobody where I'm from
or that I'm down from that because
I just handle stuff for everyone.
Things happen, because
that's the best way to do it, you know?
And that just shows that I'm
not a bitch ass punk, like
I'm no punk bitch
nobody's gonna tell me what to do and
I just,
I mean I'm not a dumb person,
I know right from wrong
and I know like morally my
beliefs and what I stand for
but when it comes to my hood,
it's like family, you know?
(loud background traffic noise)
I'm not gonna ever betray that.
- [Mark] And prison time.
(indistinct)
- Prison, I've done
like three prison terms.
(indistinct)
For robbery, the first term.
And then another was a
home invasion and robbery.
And I have
two cars I stole
I guess nobody ever says that, you know
that's something they wanna grow up doing,
it's just
stuff happens, shit happens,
you know life happens and
for gang members like us
it's not a choice.
You just do what you
gotta do, no matter what.
For your family
and for your brothers and sisters.
You know, like your hood.
- [Mark] Is a female gang
member treated differently
than a male?
- They are, a lot in ways.
Especially back, way back.
Now it's more like we have
to fuckin' be as good,
we have to be as hard,
or as ready to, like,
to bust a cap on someone almost
You gotta just be quick
to be a killer and it's-
but that's every day life.
You know what I mean?
Where I grew up, where I come
from, that's just automatic.
It's like in your basic tools for life.
Number one, survival.
Either you're a shark, or you're gonna be
- [Mark] Eaten.
- Eaten, yeah.
I know that if it gets down to you or me,
it's not gonna be me, I'll say that.
Do I dance with the devil
on a daily basis? Yes.
Playing with my life, period,
is a ballsy thing, you know?
It's a ballsy thing to
live through the life
that we have to live through.
In today's times and-
I don't know.
Don't get me wrong.
What I have, what I do,
how I react,
it's a product of my
environment, you know?
Like, just being in prison, you know.
We heard that a baby
case was coming up, and
a lot of times we don't, like it's not-
(indistinct)
"oh, fuck it.
Let me go pluck this
bitch cause I know I can."
No, I wasn't raised like
that in my hood generation.
There's older women that
sat me down, you know.
When I got jumped into my
neighborhood, there was-
- [Mark] When you what?
- When I got jumped into
my hood, at fourteen,
I got jumped in by two guys and two girls.
That don't mean nothing if you're a guy.
You're gonna check the honey,
you're gonna go check her right now.
You're gonna fuckin' give
it to her, just the same way
I would, or you know, or he would.
So, like, everybody is treated
the same way in that aspect.
But, like, when it comes to-
we have ethics and codes
when it comes to gangs, too.
We don't, you're not supposed to, like-
you don't-
We get checked, or we could
get, we could even get
a green light on us, if we
shoot and do a drive-by,
which drive-bys are no longer allowed, but
if we were, and there was a child,
that's already a dead man
walking, you know, pretty much.
But like in prison,
We get word that somebody's a baby case
and that they need to be taken
care of because, you know?
That's an innocent child, and
it don't matter who it is,
who they know, doesn't
matter; that's a dead-
Once they hit ground and they're
not gonna know it's coming.
I had like six people just stab,
stab her just as she
came up to the jail hole.
It's sad when like
you can see things like that
and it's normal to you.
It doesn't affect you anymore
because you've just been so-
I don't know, like people
who go to the war, you know?
I look at it the same way.
This is my war ground;
and I know the best ways to go about it
with the people I battle.
- [Mark] Have you ever killed anybody?
- I can't say that
anybody has ever died from
whatever I've done to them but
I know that they always,
they always had it coming.
It wasn't just because, just to do it.
I mean that's something,
me, I have to deal with
for the rest of my life.
If I know I've killed somebody
or if I know that because of the things
I've done to that person
that maybe they didn't wake
up the next day, whatever.
I don't know, I've never
been told that like-
I've never been convicted of it, so
- [Mark] Never been caught.
- There's a lot of us
that haven't been caught
for a lot of things, you know?
Life evens out that way, you know?
- [Mark] Do you have kids of your own?
(Clears throat)
- I do
(laughs nervously)
It's crazy cause being a mom and being
in the gang life, being
active, so to speak,
(clears throat)
a lot of people will respect the fact that
I won't do certain things.
My hood, they'll respect certain things
that I choose not to do.
I explain to whoever it is that like
"hey, I don't feel comfortable
doing this person because
that's some personal shit,
and that has nothing to do with the hood,
so like, I'm not gonna".
Or respect the fact
that I'm, you know, now,
I'm a little more chilled
now than I was back then.
I was a hot head back then, you know?
Capped people right there,
right in front of their face.
Just because I fucking got mad or like
jacked somebody just because,
you know I'm sick of them
I fucking,
it's not about nothing else
except me getting what I want
at the time that I need it.
And if it's money for my kids
or if it's money that I need
to help my homeboy's mom
or like anything like that.
It's just, it'll happen.
I'll make it happen. And-
for me, because I'm hot-headed
I don't think about it, I just do it.
I don't know, I guess
I knew what I signed up when
I signed up for it, you know?
I wanted all this.
I thrive for this stuff.
It's like a person that's
fucking addicted to
drugs, it's like a drug.
- [Mark] You think
anything in your childhood,
the way you were raised,
that it has something to do with that?
- [Hazel] Well my family,
for one. Because they just-
they're there but they're never there.
They're not there at all.
I look at it like this-
if my parents, or my dad,
whoever gave a fuck about
me really be out there,
how come they weren't like
those other moms that had-
my friends had moms that fuckin'
cooked for them every day.
Made sure they fuckin'
ate. If they weren't home,
they were calling
everybody looking for them.
I didn't have that. Like-
maybe cause they were too
busy in their own shit, but
either way, I went
looking for what I needed.
I can't say it was wrong, but I can't say-
I don't think I'm an angel,
you know? Or nor my friends.
But I know that we stand
for something, I do.
When it comes to my neighborhood
I look at them like my
brothers and sisters.
I'll treat them just the way
I would treat my own family
and if anybody got crazy with them
fucking locked up on them, I
would be right there with them.
Believe it or not, the
first time I got locked up
with anybody in my life was
when I got jumped into my hood.
I never had a fight before.
I don't know if it was
just me holding back
cause I don't really bother nobody, but
- [Mark] So that was your initiation?
- My initiation, yeah,
was getting down with two
of my homeboys and two of my homegirls.
Cause like I said, I was always like-
- [Mark] So the fight was the initiation?
- Yeah, you get jumped.
It's not jumped
but it looks like that to
people that don't know.
But like, I mean, it's our
own brothers and sisters.
People that are gonna
love you and fight for you
and die for you if-
I mean, they have that right, you know
to set you straight, so
Me, I've had to be set
straight a lot of times
because I'm just a little
firecracker, you know
I don't think about
stuff, but I don't know.
I think when I was about nine or ten,
I got in trouble because
I fought some girl.
Okay so it's before then, but
when I was like nine or ten
I don't think it was
really a fight though, like
you're a kid, you know?
But I just had a lot of
anger ever since I was a kid
I think that's what's fueled
me to boss up on bitches
Just you know, like "What?
What'd you say bitch? What's up?"
Cause me, I can talk, don't get me wrong
I know how to talk, I can't
talk when it comes to arguing.
I'll start stuttering. And to me I'm like-
- [Guest] Cause that's
how mad you're getting?
- Yeah, I ain't tryna
look like a little bitch
(indistinct)
"Fool, you punked out, oh hell naw"
No, that's not me. I'm like, no.
(laughs)
- [Guest] I think that's how
everybody gets when they're-
- And I think that's what kinda helps too.
Kinda gives you that
little boost. You're like,
"Fuck that. I can't
look like a little bitch
in front of the homies"
So you're like fuck that.
"What?!"
And you just take off, you know.
But like, I mean, I stabbed this guy for
for me personally because
I was raised by my father,
but my father was there
but he wasn't there.
He clothed me, he raised
me, put food on the table
but like, I had-
I had no respect for him. I feared him.
And fear for me, now is like
"Whatchu gonna do? Like
whatchu gonna do?" You know?
Because I've pretty
much danced with death-
I took a chance with
death every day, you know
I could walk out right now
and somebody could do a
drive-by, somebody could shoot.
Somebody could just be waiting.
Anything can happen.
But, that's what keeps me on my toes, too.
I dress the way I dress
because it's a part of me and who I am.
How I feel about myself.
How I feel that I know I'm the man.
You know that song?
Feel like the man when you walk through.
I feel like the woman when I walk through.
Like I have that respect.
I know people are gonna
like, people come to me
they're like, "What's up Hazel?"
That let me know what's
the get-down, you know?
And I'll be like, "All right"
Or they need something, people
know they can come to me
and "Hazel, get it for me."
Or it depends, whatchu need?
- [Mark] So what kind of
things have you done for money?
- For money, for jobs, or-
Well, let me put it like this.
I'm 38 years old. I've never
had a job in my entire life.
I've never worked a 9-5 job.
- [Guest] Me either!
(guest chuckles)
- But one time, you know
that was this recent, last-
or 2019
and 2017
like November
like July, August,
September, October, all that.
I got in prison and I had to
have my daughter in prison
for the first time I
had a child in prison.
It was fucked up, but like
It is what it is. Huh?
- [Mark] You and your daughter
were in prison together?
- Yeah.
She started off in CIW
And she's a little, she's
a hardcore one cause
I don't know, she's the
only one I didn't get to-
I didn't get to be around
because, well, things happen.
People change. People choose to move on.
Sometimes telling you, and
sometimes not telling you.
And that's another thing
chipped on my shoulder.
Oh fuck no! Doesn't he know who I am?
Doesn't he know, like
doesn't he know what the fuck I'll do?
He don't know me very well.
He don't wanna do that.
He don't wanna hurt me but then it's like-
He's not worth me fucking
having him taken out
or like whatever I have to do cause like-
At the end of the day, he's
still the father of my child and
I would never wanna do that-
I would never do that to
my child, you know, like
I wanna see the pain in their eyes because
I know what I did to
their father knowing that
they're just tired of not
having a father, you know?
But like I think I cried over
a lot, of not having my mom.
Probably till this day, to be honest.
I still do. Every now and then.
My mom is alive but my mom
is like still gangster.
She's doing her gangster days,
her gangster ways, you know?
My mom's quick to tell
us straight out, like
"You guys are grown, it's me
and my wife, and we're one"
I don't like her wife a lot of times.
I've had to beat her up twice.
She's fucking put hands
on my mom and I'm like-
That's not gonna fucking happen.
Not in front of me, especially.
And you will respect my mom, why,
because she loves you enough to fucking
bring you a part of our
family. And that's a lot.
Cause we're not just anybody.
That's how I feel, how
I feel about my head.
We're not just anybody.
Everybody knows, if they know.
Anybody from my hood, in my neighborhood
that all my homies are strapped.
We're always ready for whatever.
Little kids are like ten
years old, they're ready.
They're just soldiers. You know?
(ambulance siren wails)
- [Mark] They carry guns?
- Sometimes. Sometimes we
hold each other's guns.
Sometimes we gotta hide guns.
It just depends and that's-
That's part of that
adrenaline life that I love.
I'm an adrenaline junkie.
In the social aspect of things,
I get my adrenaline by
possibly getting caught.
I don't know, I've always had that thrill.
It give me that adrenaline
rush. It's like exciting.
- [Mark] You mentioned that
you were into escorting?
- Escorting? Yeah I've had to-
- [Mark] Not you escorting but-
- Well the thing is, to tell the truth
I have escorted before.
I had a choice because
I knew what I was doing.
But I did it because
I didn't feel like I had any
other way at that time and-
I saw the way
sick men would look at
me at the age that I was
and I was like,
"You know what fuck that,
I'm gonna get this fool.
I'm gonna get him for all his shit".
So not only did I rob him but
I fucking got whatever else I felt made me
feel like that was fair.
How do you say it? No
robbery for exchange?
But really you just got everything,
and what are you gonna say?
Cause you were fucking
tryna fuck with a child?
Or like a kid? You know?
I think I stabbed this man,
I don't know what ever happened to him.
I never saw him again but like-
He tried to touch me and stuff and
I don't know, it's something like a fear.
He gave me, I don't know, I guess-
like the women have the
instinct, you know like-
Something's not safe,
something's now right and
I don't know, he like
grabbed me in a weird way
and I was like "What the fuck, hell naw".
So that's why I always carry something.
I don't care.
(indistinct)
I'm not even supposed to
be having it, but like
I don't care, no matter what
My people know that I'm always
gonna have something on me.
It doesn't matter what.
And you might not know what it is,
because I rather you not see it coming.
If I have to put a razor blade in my mouth
or fucking put it in my hair
or in between my fingers, like anything.
Us being females, you know like
we could play a dude real quick.
Be like, "What's up?"
On a hookup tip, you know.
Lure them in and then fucking
just do what I gotta do.
Because he's a dumb ass and he's fucking-
he's my enemy and I gotta
get him before he gets me
or anybody else he might hurt.
- [Mark] All right, Hazel.
Thank you very much.
- Thank you very much.